D
RIDE OUT THE BRUTAL STORM THAT
HAS NO SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN GREG STEUBE
JOINS ME NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, THAT LOOKS PRETTY
ROUGH BACK THERE ARE YOU SURE
THIS WAS A GOOD IDEA?
>> YEAH, IT'S ACTUALLY WORSE
THAN WHAT YOU SEE BEHIND ME
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I'M IN
NORTHEAST SARASOTA COUNTY.
SO THE EYE IS STARTING TO MAKE
ITS WAY INTO THIS AREA OF THE
STATE.
BUT MY HEART GOES OUT TO MY
DISTRICT.
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA AND CHARLOTTE
COUNTY BECAUSE IT IS NOT GOING
TO LOOK THE SAME AFTER THIS
STORM.
WE HAVE PEOPLE ON LITTLE GAS
PARRILLO ISLAND.
WE HAVE 16-FOOT STORM SURGE.
WE HAVE WINDS OF 155 MILES PER
HOUR.
THINGS I HAVEN'T SEEN I HAVE
BEEN IN THIS AREA MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN HERE FOR
GENERATIONS.
I CERTAINLY HAVEN'T SEEN THE
DEVASTATION THAT WE ARE SEEING
NOW.
CERTAINLY IN CHARLOTTE COUNTY
AND NORTH FORT MYERS WHICH WILL
BE THE EPICENTER OF THE HIT.
SO WHEN WE COME BACK TOMORROW
AND THE SUSPECT COMES UP YOU ON
THE GREAT DISTRICT OF FLORIDA A
LOT OF EXASPERATION.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH
THE BRAVE -- OR ARE YOU SAD A
LOT OF KNUCKLE HEADS DECIDED TO
RIDE IT OUT.
>> WE HAVE FREEDOM IN FLORIDA.
WE HAVE FREEDOM TO BE NOT SO
SMART.
AND THERE IS 31 PEOPLE -- I
TALKED TO THE CHARLOTTE COUNTY
SHERIFF EARLIER TODAY AND THERE
WERE 31 PEOPLE THAT STAYED ON
LITTLE GASPARILLA ISLAND WHICH
IS A SMALL BARRIER ISLAND.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF WHY WOULD
YOU DO THAT WITH AN 18-FOOT
STORM SURGE COMING YOUR WAY.
UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO SEE SOME CATASTROPHIC
NOT ONLY HUMAN TOLLS BUT
PROPERTY TOLLS FROM THIS STORM
AND, HEY, PEOPLE HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO MAKE THE DECISION,
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SAID TO
EVACUATE, ESPECIALLY FROM THE
BARRIER ISLANDS.
MOST PEOPLE DID AGREE WITH THAT
AND MOVE OUT.
I HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE EVEN IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE STATE THAT
LIVED IN FIFTH WHEELS OR TRAILER
HOMES OR MOBILE HOMES THAT
DECIDED TO MOVE NORTH.
AND THAT WAS A SMART DECISION
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING IN NORTH
SARASOTA COUNTY WINDS UP TO
100 MILES PER HOUR AND IN WHERE
THE CENTER OF THE STORMS CAME
THROUGH, OBVIOUSLY, 104 TO 150
MILE-PER-HOUR WINDS WHICH IS
DEVASTATING WINDOW TOLL.
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE ALL
ASSETS ON THE GROUND AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES CAN'T GET BACK OUT
UNTIL TOMORROW.
>> Jesse: I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE A
TON OF LOCAL AND STATE ASSETS
PREPOSITIONED READY TO ROCK.
>> YES, WE DO.
>> Jesse: HOW HAS THE
COOPERATION BEEN WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
IT'S BEEN SURPRISING BEING A
REPUBLICAN AND NEVER GETTING
ANSWERS FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
ASKING SECRETARY MAYORKAS IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND SUDDENLY
HE CALMS ME ON MY CELL PHONE
TODAY ASKING IF THERE IS
ANYTHING I NEED.
WE NEED THE COAST GUARD TO COME
DOWN TO GASPARILLA ISLAND TO
SAVE INDIVIDUALS STRANDED THERE
ONCE THE CONDITIONS ARE SAFE
ENOUGH TO GET OUR COAST GUARD IN
THERE.
I HAVE HAD PEOPLE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION REACH OUT TO ME.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
THIS IS GOODS TO TAKE A FEDERAL
RESPONSE AND STATE RESPONSE AND
COUNTY RESPONSE.
THERE IS NO WAY THAT THE STATE
OF FLORIDA CAN BE ABLE TO FUND
THE TYPE OF THINGS GOING IT NEED
TO BE FUNDED HERE.
I HAVE ALREADY ASKED BLARLT
BLART WHO IS ON APPROPRIATIONS
FOR DISASTER RELIEF FUNDING.
KAT CAMMACK.
ALSO A FLORIDA REPUBLICAN WHO IS
THE RANCHER ON FEMA.
EVERYBODY IS ALL HANDS ON DECK
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA AS IT
RELATES TO HELPING EVERYBODY
THAT NEEDS TO BE HELPED AND WE
ARE GOING TO NEED IT AFTER THIS
STORM ROLLS THROUGH AND YOU SEE
THE DEVASTATION THAT'S GOING TO
COME FROM IT.
>> Jesse: WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
RESTORING POWER, ELECTRICITY,
THE CELL SERVICE, SOME OF THE
TOWERS HAVE BEEN KNOCKED OUT.
WHAT'S THE LATEST WITH
COMMUNICATIONS?
>> MY CELL SERVICE IS DOWN.
FORTUNATELY I HAVE A GENERATOR
HERE I'M ABLE TO TALK TO YOU AND
HAVE WIFI CONNECTIVITY.
I CAN TEXT THROUGH iPHONE AND
THAT SORT OF THING.
CELL PHONE TOWERS ARE DOWN.
A MILLION FLORIDIANS THAT
CURRENTRY DO NOT HAVE POWER.
>> AND LAW ENFORCEMENT, E.M.S.
AND POWER COMPANIES CANNOT GO
OUT AS LONG AS THE SUSTAINED
WINDS ARE OVER 45 MILES PER
HOUR, WHICH IS WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW.
I BET IT'S 90 TO 100 MILES PER
HOUR IN SARASOTA COUNTY.
YOU ARE SEEING THAT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THEY ARE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET OUT UNTIL EARLY
TOMORROW MORNING TO BE ABLE
RESTORE SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WHILE.
JUST HERE ON MY PROPERTY WE HAVE
TREES DOWN EVERYWHERE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE SITUATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THEY HAVE TO SEND PUSH CREWS
THROUGH TO BE ABLE TO CLEAR THE
ROADS.
TO BE ABLE TO SEND THOSE CREWS
DOWN.
AND SOME OF THE HARDEST HIT
AREAS THEY MAY NOT HAVE POWER
FOR WEEKS.
CELL PHONE CONNECTIVITY MAY BE
ALSO CHALLENGING.
BUT, ALL OF THOSE RESOURCES ARE
STAGED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE HAVE POWER COMPANIES STAGED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND READY
TO RESPOND AS SOON AS THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
COME OUT IS AVAILABLE FOR THEM
TO DO THAT.
BUT GOOD MORNING THAT'S GOING TO
BE UNTIL TOMORROW MORNING.
WE COULD HAVE FLORIDIANS WITHOUT
POWER FOR WEEKS HERE IN
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA.
>> Jesse: OH MY GOD.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, CONGRESSMAN,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
YOU AND ALL YOUR PEOPLE IN YOUR
DISTRICT DOWN THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
>> YEA